en ese debate se debatieron temas que no
habían aparecido en los debates
anteriores de primera vuelta
se debatió educación en eso Lula le ganó
mucha ventaja a personal o le hizo
preguntas como puentes universidades has
creado en tu gobierno y y bolsonaro
Simplemente no tenía quieres que
contestar el tema de la pandemia también
que es un tema que que no había sido
mencionado en los debates de la primera
vuelta parecía que la gente todavía
había superado ese tema pero ahora Lula
finalmente está una postura de
enfrentamiento por solaro porque en los
debates anteriores tampoco Lula
enfrentaba así violentamente a
bolsonaros
mostrando todos los equipos
de su gobierno principalmente en el
manejo de la pandemia porque es el la
pandemia le da mucho material a que un
candidato en frente a personal y bueno
Lula enfatizó mucho el tema de que
bolsonaro tardó muchísimo a comprar las
vacunas que eso resultó familiares de
muertes
dijo incluso yo soy su obra había muerto
de y bolsonaro dijo una frase como la
que ahora y son discurso en altavoz de
su exmujer algo así en el tema de
seguridad pública que teóricamente le
daría más ventaja a bolsonar porque
bolsonaro es el candidato preferido de
los funcionarios de las fuerzas de
seguridad los policías las fuerzas
armadas Lula también
supo enfrentarlo muy bien una vez que
bolsonaron no creó ninguna prisión de
máxima seguridad mientras logre sus
gobiernos crió cinco prisiones de máxima
seguridad
y bueno
y y para finalizar Este primer bloque
hablaron de algo para el nordeste que
fue muy arriesgado de la parte de
bolsonaro traer este tema porque
el nordeste del país está
mayoritariamente
apoyando a Lula incluso es prácticamente
gracias a los electores de esa región
que que Lula que Lula está encabezando
las encuestas las intenciones de Voto
entonces bolsonaro hablando de de amigos
los destinos compañeros los destinos no
sé si fue una estrategia muy inteligente
Lula también subo contestarlo de una
manera muy inteligente dijo que la
transferencia de agua fue todo todo un
proyecto suyo que él había ejecutado el
88% del proyecto de transferencia de
agua mientras evolucionaron
tan solo había quedado con la
responsabilidad de cómo hacer un 3% del
proyecto entonces en lo general Yo diría
que los temáticas habían florecido al
presidente Lula